écouter le discours du candidat dans
marche qui donc âgé de 39 ans bien pour
la première fois sans avoir été élu au
paravant arrive en tête de ce premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle vous
le voyez sur ces images il est
accompagné par son épouse Brigitte et il
va tout de suite s'exprimer on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à
vousident Macon président Macon
président Mac président ma président ma
président ma président ma
président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
président
voilà
voilà mes chers compatriotes
aujourd'hui dimanche 23
avril le peuple de France s'est
[Musique]
exprimé alors que notre pays traverse un
moment inédit de son histoire marqué par
le terrorisme les défis économiques les
souffrances sociales et l'urgence
écologique il y a répondu de la plus
belle manière en allant voter
massivement il a
[Musique]
décidé il a décidé de me porter en tête
du premier tour de ce
[Applaudissements]
scrutinésident
président
présidentésident
je mesure l'honneur et l'insigne
responsabilité qui ainsi me
revient je veux ici ce soir saluer les
autres candidats présents au premier
tour Nathalie au françoiselino Jacques
Cheminade François Fillon Nicolas du
ponignan Benoît amont Jean L Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Philippe
pou merci à vous de les avoir tous et
toutes applaudis à l'instant cela vous
ressemble cela nous
ressemble je sais la déception de celles
et ceux qui les soutenaient et la leure
je remercie Benoît amont et François
Fillon d'avoir appelé à voter en ma
faveur au second
tour à tous ceux qui depuis avril 2016
m'ont accompagné en créant et en faisant
vivre en marche je veux dire ce soir
quelques
mots en une année nous avons le visage
de la vie politique
française le sentiment profond organique
millénaire qui a toujours porté notre
peuple l'engagement pour la patrie
l'énergie pour l'intérêt collectif
au-delà des divisions l'ont emporté ce
soir
je n'oublierai jamais la volonté
opignatre l'énergie
exigeante que des milliers d'entre vous
ont déployé pour que cela
advienne depuis 1
an partout en
France vous avez pris votre part du
destin national vous avez su montrer que
l'espoir pour notre pays n'était pas un
rêve une lubie ou une bulle mais bien
une volonté acharnée et
bienveillante vous avez donné vos jours
et quand il ne suffisait pas vous avez
donné vos
nuits ce soir ce soir mes amis je vous
le dois et je le
sais il vous revient de poursuivre cet
engagement vibrant jusqu'au bout et
au-delà ne renoncez jamais n'oubliez
jamais ces mois durant lesquels vous
avez changé le cours de notre pays et
fait mentir les assis restez les
courageux exigeants que vous êtes il
vous appartient désormais de poursuivre
ce
chemin dès ce soir je me dois d'aller
au-delà et de rassembler tous les
Français je ne serai jamais loin de
vous et j'auraai toujours besoin de
VOUS aux millions de Françaises et de
Français qui m'ont ce soir fait
confiance en votant pour moi je veux
dire
merci je veux
dire merci merci merci merci merci merci
merci
mercici je veux dire que j'en mesure la
charge et c'est ce soir une joie grave
lucide qui
m'habite en votre nom je porterai pour
le deuxème tour de cette élection
l'exigence de l'optimisme et la voix de
l'espoir que nous voulons pour notre
pays et pour
l'Europe au mien je veux dire merci à
ceux qui sont là et à ceux qui ne sont
plus car on ne fait rien de bien en
oubliant qui l'on est et d'où l'on vient
à toute ma famille et à
Brigitte
toujours présente et encore davantage
sans laquelle je ne serais pas
moi désormais désormais mes amis il me
revient de rassembler plus largement
encore de réconcilier notre France pour
gagner dans 15 jour et demain pour
présider notre
paysag on va gagner on va gagner on va
gagner on va gager on va gagner on va
gagner on va gag on va
gagnerag j'ai entendu durant ces
derniers mois et encore aujourd'hui les
doutes la colère les peurs du peuple de
France sa volonté de changement aussi
c'est celle-ci qui a conduit à écarter
ce soir des responsabilités les deux
grands partis qui la gouvernent depuis
plus de 30
ans
je veux ce soir m'adresser à tous les
citoyens de France de la France de
l'Hexagone comme de celle des
outresmes je sais vos
attentes je souhaite dans 15 jours
devenir votre
président le président de tout le peuple
de France
le président des patriotes face à la
menace des
nationalistes un président qui protège
qui transforme et qui construit un
président qui permette à ceux qui
veulent créer innover entreprendre
travailler de le faire plus facilement
et plus vite
un président qui aide ceux qui ont moins
qui sont plus fragiles ou bousculés par
la vie à travers l'école la santé le
travail la
solidarité j'ai entendu vos aspirations
à l'alternance
véritable à la vitalité démocratique à
l'exigence écologique et
économique pour construire un avenir
possible qui rendra la France plus forte
dans une Europe qui protège j'aurais
besoin de votre vote j'aurais besoin de
votre
confiance
j'vrerai mes chers compatriotes dans les
15 jours qui viennent pour que nous
puissions ensemble rassembler le plus
largement possible autour de ma
candidature la force de ce rassemblement
sera déterminante pour présider et pour
gouverner le défi à partir de ce
soir n'est pas d'aller contre qui que ce
soit le défi est de décider de rompre
jusqu'au bout avec le système qui a été
incapable de répondre aux problèmes de
notre pays depuis plus de 30
ans le défi est d'ouvrir une nouvelle
page de notre vie politique et d'agir
pour que chacun avec justice et
efficacité puisse trouver sa place en
France et en Europe c'est cela notre
défi c'est pourquoi mes chers
compatriotes je veux dès à présent
construire une majorité de gouvernement
et de transformation nouvelle
elle sera faite de nouveaux visages de
nouveaux
talents chacune et chacun peut y avoir
sa
place je ne demanderai pas à ceux qui me
rejoignent d'où ils viennent mais s'ils
sont d'accord pour le renouveau de notre
vie politique pour assurer la sécurité
des Français pour libérer le travail
pour refonder l'école pour permettre à
chacun de progresser dans la société
d'où qu'ils viennent et pour relancer la
construction
[Applaudissements]
européenne
président
[Applaudissements]
présidzès ce so
la part du risque qui vous revient pour
me rejoindre ainsi que la majorité
parlementaire que je construirai dès
demain mes chers
concitoyens vous l'avez
fait vous nous avez
porté vous avez montré qu'il n'y avait
dans notre pays aucune
fatalité
vous êtes ce visage du
renouveau vous êtes ce visage de
l'espoir Français celui que dans 15
jours je veux faire
[Applaudissements]
gagnerés
mes chers concitoyens il n'y a pas
plusieurs Frances il n'y en a qu'une la
France la nôtre la France des patriotes
dans une Europe qui protège et que nous
aurons à
refonder la tâche sera
immense j'y suis prêt à vos
côtés
le combat pour être digne de conduire
notre pays commence ce soir et nous le
gagnerons vive la
République vive la
[Applaudissements]
France
merci à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous